You're going spying?
I’m going to see some history that is happening today.
Well Hello, I’m Jane Lynch.
Hi! I’m Lacey Chabert.
Hey There! It’s Beanie Feldstein and I play Harriet M. Welsch
in the newSeries Harriet the Spy. The character you may
already know and lovebut you’ve never seen our
fearless heroine quite like this.
I play Ole Golly, Harriet’s nanny and mentor.
Remember: life is a struggle and a good spy never quits.
I play Marion Hawthorne, Harriet’s classmate, and well, whatever
you’ve heard about Marion,
I promise you don’t know the whole story.
She’s a mean, rotten person who Janie and I
will someday get revenge on.
Here’s things you didn’t know about Harriet the Spy.
Harriet’s absolutefavorite food is tomato sandwiches,
just white bread, tomato and mayonnaise.
Her favorite color is red, because
it’s the color of her signature hoodie.
Her worst enemy is Marion Hawthorne.
I finished early so if anyone is still struggling,
I can, of course, helpthem out.
Ugh buzz off Marion!
Marion wins at everything.
I won with the word onomatopoeia.
Marion has excellent taste in fashion.
Tres chic, no?
But you better not wear the same thing that she’s wearing.
She doesnot consider imitation the highest form of flattery.
Please tell me that coat isn’t made by Smithers of London.
Marion and Harriet were friends when they were younger.
Time to grow up, Harriet!
They couldn’t be more different.
When Harriet has questions, Ole Golly always has the answers.
Andthere’s a lot you might not know about Ole Golly.
She always knows the right thing to say.
To be a writer, you need to see and know everything.
She’s book-smart and street-smart.
Hey, watch where you’re going!
Her middle name is Willa.
Willa? What kind of a name is that anyway?
Well, it’s better than being a Myrtle!
She has some things to learn, too.
Ole Golly, I don’t just want to be a writer – I want to be a great writer.
Well that means you’ve got to know everything.
You might think you know Harriet, but like every good spy,
she’s gotmore up her sleeve.
I’m Harriet M. Welsch, and I will witness history in the making!